I am taking this month off and while I'm
away some other folks are taking over my
channel we start this week with a couple
of astronomy and physics majors who
along with professor Chris MP and their
team at the University of Arizona make a
channel called active galactic videos
now the video they've sent is a little
rough around the edges in places but the
idea is so good that I am genuinely
annoyed that I couldn't go out and film
this myself so Jenny Melissa the GMT is
being built in Chile at the Las Campanas
Observatory in the Atacama Desert and
it's scheduled to see first light in
2022 this massive telescope will have
ten times the resolution of the Hubble
Space Telescope and more than seven
times the light gathering power of the
largest telescopes today the GMT is made
of seven eight and a half metre mirrors
for a total diameter of 25 metres and it
will be used to study galaxies stars and
exoplanets the GMT 5 which is the mere
being cast right now actually the 20th
mirror made at this facility other
mirrors have been made for other
telescopes like the MMT the large
synoptic survey telescope the twin
Magellan telescopes and the large
binocular telescope it was built under
the stadium to take advantage of the
large columns which act as load-bearing
structures for all the heavy equipment
needed it's also nice and quiet when
there aren't football games going on
it's a great way to make football
benefit both the University and science
to start off we need thirty eight
thousand five hundred forty pounds of
glass
sandé the ship from all over the world
and brought to Japan to the ohhara glass
factory they're the only factory in the
world that can make the e6 low expansion
glass that's needed for the GMT mirrors
the glass is made in two thousand pound
batches made exclusively for the
University of Arizona it takes around
two and a half years to make enough
glass for a single mirror so you know
plan ahead the glass isn't shipped here
to Tucson
once the mirror lab gets it they have to
clean it inspect it and weigh it if
there are any stresses or imperfections
in the glass and the piece is rejected
and made into paper weights each
individual piece of glass is placed
carefully into the mold and inside the
oven the 40 foot diameter oven is
ungraduated to a temperature of 1,350
degrees Fahrenheit over the course of a
week there are cameras in the oven to
monitor the process but once it begins
there's no turning back at this point
the massive oven is filled with 19 tons
of glass and starts to spin five
revolutions per minute once the oven
reaches 2129 degrees Fahrenheit or 1165
degrees Celsius the consistency of the
glass is about the same as honey and
starts to flow into the mold it spins to
make the shape we need for a mirror a
parabola modern telescopes use parabolic
mirrors to collect and concentrate light
they use the parabolic shape to get the
light into a central focus point and the
bigger the mirror the more light is
collected but what does this have to do
with spinning besides making us dizzy
well let's take a look so it turns out
that spinning a liquid actually causes
it to automatically become this
parabolic shape so whenever you spin the
glass it creates the perfect shape
needed for a mirror this is a massive
improvement over how mirrors used to be
made and it grinds years off the process
the mirror spends three months cooling
and annealing in the oven
so now it's the right shape but it isn't
quite done yet when light hits the
mirror the surface has to be smoother
than a fraction of the wavelength of
light otherwise the image is distorted
in order to get at this smooth the
mirror laughs spends two years polishing
the glass it has to be smooth to the
point where no imperfection on the
surface is larger than a virus after all
that after melting the glass in this
giant oven and polishing it for two
years all you have is a huge really
smooth piece of glass so the mirror lab
actually doesn't make any mirrors the
final step in turning this giant piece
of glass into a mirror is actually done
on-site at the observatory a layer of
aluminum about a hundred nanometers
thick is deposited on to the surface to
cover a mirror of this size it actually
only takes a soda cans worth of metal
unlike your mirrors at home the
reflective coating is only on the front
surface so it's very delicate and needs
to be realized every so many years thank
you to everyone here at the Richard F
Karis mirror lab and the steward
observatory tours are open to the public
every day of the week go subscribe to
active galactic videos for more like
that I would recommend starting with the
video where they get to walk on the dish
of a telescope and yes I am extremely
envious that they got to do that next
week a language video that you are
probably going to need subtitles for